there is a smell there there is um you
never you never get used to it it's it's
hard I mean some guys in in the um mtry
that some you know sometimes you put um
fit onto your nose or some smelling ins
salts or or you know something but no I
I I cope with that that's that's just
part and parcel of my job
[Music]
really
when and why did you decide to become
matician well it was 27 years ago um I
lost my grandparents in a couple of
weeks of one another obviously it was a
really hard time for my mom she was 50
in between that and and um and usually
when especially years ago you just used
to use the local Funeral Directors but
it was only my my brother-in-law said oh
oh I know my my cousin works at cribs in
in in beckon so we said oh okay we'll
use them and that's what we did um and I
thought well because they helped us all
I want to do is help another family I
was um a qualified Beautician and I used
to do friends wedding makeups and all
things like that wedding parties makeup
parties and it was my sister-in-law at
the time um she rang them and said oh do
you remember us and and um John saides
yeah I do so she said oh Debbie would
really like to get into this so he said
oh come down and when you've went there
and kind of saw it all did it not be
your off I thought it would and
especially being in the um the room that
my nan was in and it was a
gentleman um and I thought oh like I I
thought I'd but it didn't I think it
because of losing my nana and Grandad so
so quickly
I think I thought I was being close to
them I felt closer because I was around
sort of death if that makes sense but it
was fine so they went round the back um
to the fridges and and then from then on
I did all my courses there so um and
I've been doing it ever
since so what exactly does a matician do
what do you do so straight away once the
the body's been embalmed sometimes
they're not but if they're being viewed
they they will be embalmed um so what it
does it um you take the blood out of one
and then the you know EMB Bing fluid
goes in so it preserves the body and it
can preserve the body for a long long
time once it's in the fridge um so once
that is all done then it's my job then
to come in and and I'll I will dress and
I will do the hair makeup I've dyed hair
before I've done spray tans I paint
their
nails um anything that needs to be done
I would do then dress them and then um I
usually wait and wait for them to go
into the coffin or their casket
rearrange and then then then then
they're ready for viewing with the
family I've I have got my own makeup um
which is like theatrical makeup so it is
a lot lot thicker um where I've been
doing it so long I kind of know
someone's died of cancer because their
skin will be yellow um I kind of know
but so once I know once I've I've gone
in and I've viewed who who I'm doing um
I I do have there are some products that
you can spray so you get an
even um you know an even coverage if
they've got because depending on how
they died you their blood would be so if
they died and fell on their face their
blood so that you can never get rid of
that so I've got makeup to cover that
but if some families want their own
makeup I can do that too and I do do
some
of Their Own Makeup um but usually I do
try and cover it up so you know there is
more of a
coverage a lot thicker than what we
would use in terms of um Recon like any
kind of reconstruction work like if
someone was shot I don't know was an
accident or something yeah we did I did
um my partner and I went out to Chicago
to do the charman rec Construction in
America it is more shootings here it's
stabbings
um if someone was in a car accident we
can then build them up so the family can
then see them CU usually we would say
they you know they're not they're not
for viewing but now now that we can do
that it we can actually um let the
family see the body in terms of the
smells cuz everyone assumes that a dead
body smells like how do you deal with
that and also do you use any perfumes or
anything like that no you you never get
used to it there is a smell there there
is um
you never you never get used to it it's
it's hard I mean some guys in in the um
mtre that some you know sometimes you
put um fi onto your nose or some
smelling salts or or you know something
but no I I I cope with that that's
that's just part and parcel of my job
really um but again when families will
say like they use a certain perfume I
would spray that on them anyway so um
but no it's something that you you do
get used to but it is it is a a
different type of smell and in terms of
um anything with the hair like do you do
you do just kind of like a blow dryer
something yeah yeah wash and yeah wash
it can't blow dry if it's an elderly
lady um more often than not if they was
in a home they would have someone come
in and they have a set don't they a blow
dry set I try and do the same so that
they would always you know look exactly
the same as they was just before they
passed so I always ask a family for a a
photo or a recent photo sometimes I get
one back in 1970s that looked nothing
like them but more often than not I do
get a recent photo and then I can um try
and get it as as as near as possible but
this is obviously a young person which I
have done quite a few times um they've
they've um asked specifically you know
can you dieet can you do this can you
straighten it can you curl it can you um
sometimes even cut it I had a gentleman
not so long ago um because he'd been in
hospital for quite some time so his hair
had really grown so I cut all his hair
and then and more often than not as well
um with families they like a locket of
hair now so I usually cut it at the at
the back where it's not seen and and put
it in little locket bags for them so
yeah so it's it's it's everything that
you would do in life really I would do
once they've
passed and is the procedure different
for child or baby deaths I wouldn't
usually do a child because they didn't
wear makeup in yeah in life so yeah that
I mean they would be embalmed for
viewing but they wouldn't have hair and
makeup
done um like I wouldn't be called in for
for that teenagers yes because obviously
they want to be made up and you know how
they were but not not not
children can you talk us through what
are the things that happened to the body
after
death um obviously once they've died it
I mean it all depends they they go to
coroners so if if it's a a suspicious
circumstance they will go to coroners so
therefore they won't be
embed um and some coroners are longer
than others so therefore the state of
the bodies that then come back will be
slightly worse than if they died at home
or in a hospital and then they got in
baled straight
away so it it all depends on the
circumstances of of the person dying
really so and how long
decomposition um how cold the the room
is it everything does depend on
temperature I mean you know if someone
died in a flat in the baking heat it
wouldn't be very nice and it could take
a lot quicker than someone if it was in
the winter but what are the things that
happened so everything goes back yeah so
the eyes would sink the nose you know
everything sort of sinks back so there's
there's products that we we have there's
eye guards now mouth guards so we can
you know sort of piece of a face back
again do you have any kind of cases that
you remember particularly the ones that
are somehow stuck in your memory yeah
there was a a teenage girl and that that
that really sort of broke my heart um
she did get run um run over and it was
um yeah that was really sad and that
because it was my daughter's friend it
it you know it it affected me more and
and and obviously when it's someone you
know as well because it's not then
although it is my job it you feel
completely different and you're actually
under more pressure when it's someone
you know because obviously that those PE
you know your friends your family are
going to go and see that person like
when I done my nan and my stepdad for my
mom it the pressure was was really on me
because you just want them to look
perfect and and it's the
last memory they're going to have of
their loved
one so is a is a lot a lot of pressure
when it is more for someone you know
than someone you don't and do people you
know ask you to yeah I always get the
call I've had a couple this year where
the my friend's dad had died my other
friend's mama had died um and my other
friend's dad had died all and two of
them was in the same week I get the
first phone call you just want to help
someone and just make them look how they
did in life that that that is my main
goal is to help a family for their last
memory because it is the most talked
about taboo subject that everyone wants
to know don't want to know but it's
going to happen to everyone and at some
point um someone wants to see their f
family
member why do you think death is like
that like as you said like like a
subject that everyone wants to know but
no one talks about I don't know cuz I
think and the thing is it is going to
happen to everyone and
everything in life it's going to happen
isn't it but no one actually wants to
know and I I really don't know why I
think there is that element of we don't
know we don't know we all have this
belief and I think it's in every
religion that we go somewhere but no one
actually knows so um you know every
religion has a different belief of where
we go in the afterlife but I think
because none of us know we're sort of
intrigued don't we it's sort of like oh
but it's not final we just don't
know so in that sense there is something
interesting in you kind of being being
there with these people do you feel like
you have some relationship with them do
you talk to them I talk to them yeah
absolutely I I I tell them what I'm
doing and I'm doing their hair and they
doing their makeup or I'm doing their
nails um and I do believe that they are
there but only because I went to a
medium once and because it's not my you
know it is my job but it's not a
fulltime job I do it as and when um that
I went to this medium and she said oh
I've got Rose here and she said thank
you and I thought she's not very good I
don't know her Rose and um it was only
when I sort of really sat I thought oh
God I did I did a lady today and her
name was Rose and she said thank you for
doing her makeup now the medium wouldn't
have ever known that in a million years
so I do think they are there with me so
um but yeah and usually I'm on my own so
I I talk to them and yeah I tell them
everything and um and I it's I have had
a couple of occasions I've actually had
their daughters in the room with me
which is which is
not not often but again it's quite a lot
of pressure when they are there do you
find the job Hard to Handle sometimes
does it affect you or when it's someone
I know it does because you can't switch
off um when it's someone young yeah it
does because it's someone's daughter you
know sister and you can't not get
affected but because I've sort of I have
to get my work head on um but when it's
some Yow when it was my nan and I
thought I can't do that I really can't
and John said to me well you would't
want someone else to do it so I had to
do it but I mean I cried the whole time
and you know when I got her dressed and
I'd done her hair and but it was the
last thing actually I could have done
for her so I'm glad I did it um because
obviously I could never get another
chance to do it um but no it it I was
absolutely in Bits And even with my
friend's mom that I've known for um 23
24 years years um that was a cou uh in
May I think she passed away um that
really affected me because she was I was
really close to her and you know that's
my best friend's mom and that that that
does affect you it cannot not affect you
and do you think for the family overall
from your experience is it more
important for people to do open
Cask yeah uh some families don't um but
more often than not and especially with
my friends and the East end but I mean
the East End is changing now um but yeah
they are most people do view do view
now um but again you know and I think
more women do um men are very much like
oh no I want to remember them how they
were but um women do do want to you know
and and I've lost a few friends as well
and even um in their will they've put
make sure Debbie does my hair and makeup
and he's like oh no cuz I'm upset myself
but I had to do it and she was only she
was I think she was 50 when she died a
couple of years ago so that was
hard do you think what you do has
changed your view on
death yeah I'm still scared I am still
scared I felt nearer to my nana and
Grandad when obviously I first do it but
because again we don't know I I do
get scared I suppose I am scared of
death itself and losing family members
but knowing I do that gives me comfort
as well MH I think I think it might I
don't know whether it brings me nearer
to death because I'm around it I don't
know I don't know it's weird I think I
don't know I never told anyone for years
um because I think they thought I was a
freak so I never told anyone it's only
when I got into sort of like my 40s and
50s that I was sort of no actually I'm
proud and cuz I get a lot of letters and
I get you know a lot of comments and and
thank yous and so I know I've helped
someone then I think no actually I'm
proud of what I do do do when you tell
people do they start asking you a lot of
questions yeah what are the questions I
usually ask how could you do that like I
still even now even and people now even
my friends go oh I still don't know you
do that but um but I couldn't be a brain
surgeon I'd say the same to a brain
surgeon it' be like oh I don't know how
you could do that but I suppose
everyone's got there what they can and
can't do and I just think maybe that's
what I was made to do I don't
know what qualities you think are the
most important for the work you
do just caring I think it's more
compassionate I mean I'm so passionate
about it I would do it 24/7 just
thinking that I I'm helping
um
family and and it's their last memory so
I just for me it's just helping someone
now I was helping someone I think is the
biggest thing I could give back to
somebody you you never forget that do
you um do people ask to put anything in
the cast oh yeah all the time yeah so
there there'll be photos there be um
perfume they'll be um we've had
cigarettes we've had um what else have
we had um they usually like um
sentimental ornaments so like with my
friend's mom they you know we there all
photos and teddies and things like that
so yeah that that'll always go in I I
wanted to ask you about your about about
your husband because you guys both both
work in uh about your partner sorry
because you guys both work in a in a
funeral business when my n and Granddad
died we he was the funeral director
and then I then he trained me and so
that was 27 years ago but we've been
together 18 do you do you like not talk
about work at home how no no we do it's
really funny especially with with with
my girls um it and and John's three
girls are in the business
and I think it's you can't you can't
switch off because John's phones go 247
even we're on holiday so it it I think
we've all just got used to it so he'll
come and home and say how you know
what's your day oh yeah it's been really
busy covid was obviously he was going
out at halfast 5 in the morning not
coming back till 11:00 7 days a week it
was really busy but um yes so it is
quite of it's probably the main subject
in our house I guess it's also been
tough for the families cuz they couldn't
have the yeah no no that that was that
was tough and I think you know John
really
did yeah he really did suffer then
because you know you've got the families
that they they couldn't be within
hospitals with them and seeing them part
that yeah that was just a really
horrible time really horrible time it's
interesting that it seems to affect you
though you still say that you wouldn't
change it for anything and you would do
this job how does that all come together
I don't know I just think because I know
once I've like once if it was a sad
story but once I knew knew that and I've
done the hair in the makeup and I've
practically brought them back to life
because if they've been to a hospital
their hair would be pulled back and if
they didn't wear glasses it wouldn't
look like them wouldn't look like them
at all or if I put the parting on the
wrong wrong side but when when you've
done that and and and you finish and you
can look back and go wow yeah that
actually looks like that person again um
it it just it's just worth it it's just
it really is worth it
for so for so many people so many
families it's stabbings stabbing
stabbing stabbings they are the
commonest cause of death and the person
most likely to stab you is a friend or a
relative